the gyro can experience what is this
this physical training company that
you're doing you're doing something xpt
yeah what is that X PT is I would
describe it as a kind of a it's a
lifestyle program that evolved out of
what how I live like what we what we do
and so we started an experiential thing
where people can come for like two and a
half days and go through this you know
get exposed to speakers and they do heat
nice and we do pool training and breath
work and mobility conferences and
something I'm supposed to speakers like
what do you mean
well I all invite you know I would
invite you to come and speak for an hour
I'd invite Paul check or we'd have
somebody speak on longevity or
somebody's week on you know it's just
have during that during the the
experience we'll have a couple speakers
talk on you know nutrition fitness
wellness career whatever just as
something as another piece of the of the
element and then and then like I said we
have pool training and then we true and
we've been certifying trainers now to
kind of help people go through the the
process as well and so it's you know
it's it's really about rest and recovery
and breathing it's more based on on that
part it's not just another training
thing of like hey how we you know how we
can hammer you I mean I think that's
overplayed I think the ways we can train
and and how we're training is really
overplayed I think we're we're not
creating enough things that nurture the
system you know and really look at
trying to support people in there in
there in there already
you know hammering life they're already
just beating themselves down it's like
let's get off the red-eye and then we'll
go to the gym and we'll hammer ourselves
there and then we'll stay up all day and
you know and I think we they need some
support so breath work is a big part of
it knowing how to move correctly I think
that's a big part of it cuz plenty of
people hurt themselves especially in the
gym without you know without some
knowledge of movement and form mm-hmm
and then I have a pool training system I
developed which is the Gabi was telling
ya that sounds crazy yeah that's the
most proprietary thing I think we have
is
it's a marriage between the gym and the
in the pool because I despise swimming
that's you yeah well I know I do I just
want you if you said go do laps in the
pool
I'd be like Shamu and I get the floppy
fin and really oh yeah I just said I I
just that's crazy
you're [ __ ] surf no but I'm saying
but but if you said hey we're gonna take
these masks in this fins and we're gonna
swim this coastline where the waves are
breaking on the rocks and we're gonna go
for five miles I'm in like I but if you
said hey go down there and and and and
wear some swim goggles where you can't
even see and swim in some murky water
where you don't know what's in it and
we're gonna swim a mile down there and
you're gonna do that every day that D
I'd rather step on a you know rusty nail
then do that I mean it's like that's so
because of my my disdain for swimming
that kind of swimming I mean if there's
its if it's in the surf and the waves
that's a different that's a different
game that's a whole different we don't
want to do laps in the pool you'd kill
me yeah I'm gonna die I just I would
rather yeah I just I'd rather get my
hand with it it's so weird
enjoy moving in the water but I do with
some dumbbells okay so carrying a
dumbbell and jumping within dumbbells
why did you start xpt like what was the
motivation because you're obviously into
doing this stuff yourself
yeah why create a foundation or well the
reason why we started it was because an
opportunity to expose this stuff and
share with more people we were doing in
ourselves naturally and then we have
friends come and they were like this
stuff's awesome and then can I invite my
friend and then we were we realized that
that if we really wanted to expose it to
more people and share it we were gonna
it was gonna be a limitation if
everybody had to come to my house to
have like a website and every young yeah
what is the xpt like xpt life calm and
XP t stands for well my my concept is is
it exploration and performance training
there's a high performance fuels a
limitless life dumbbells in the pool
there oh yeah so this is all you are you
you have I need to yeah you have to come
well I'm just
Kyle Kingsbury yeah I love that guy
yeah the well I have some beautiful guys
come like I'll give you a great thing
that you'd appreciate is I have this
whole well first of all there's a bunch
of things that happen in the water right
which one of the things that happens is
when you're underwater the compression
of the water allows the blood to flow
through your lymphatic system which
normally takes about a 24 hour period it
happens in one hour
so imagine compression tights like you
know if you wear compression it really
helps the blood flow right well this is
the ultimate compression the water is
right so then you deal with the
psychology so it's good for Fighters
like III fighters because of the
psychology of what we can do because you
deal a lot with stress so we're able to
implement stress in a very controlled
environment and then and then and then
like for example and Grant Hill at one
point in his career but I have loved
friend Joakim Noah who's a basketball
player and we were doing these we're
doing these in the water we're doing
these dunking drills last summer so he
trained with them and get a bunch of
stuff because you can do a lot of highly
explosive heavy loaded movement with
protection because now you don't have to
worry about momentum which is what's
gonna pull your shoulder out it's gonna
be hip it's gonna hurt your knee where I
can take a basketball player and I can
run him through thousands of jumps
thousands which at the end of if I did
that on land he would be broken he's
already jumping too much in his season
he doesn't need to jump more right so I
could load him up and make him do these
dynamic movements but now he's protected
because he's because we've taken gravity
out so we're had so it's it's like it's
like saying hey we get to go trade in
outer space but it's in my backyard
right now what what kind of results of
these athletes well as parents well so
Joakim in his career and I don't know
how many years he's been in the NBA he
came back after doing this dunking job
just using this as an example and it had
the most dunks per minute that he's had
in his entire career whoa he was like
dunking on it was slamming on everybody
I mean it helps that he's seven feet
tall but the fact is is that he he he
noticed now you know Grant Hill was
talking about he gained three inches in
the last year of his career after
playing in the NBA for 20 years off city
jump and three inches higher
yeah yeah so I mean we're getting well
I'm that's the kind of tangible stuff
that I'm that I that I'm getting just
that there's a lot more things a lot of
it has to do with breath because in the
water it's all controlled breathing
patterns so everything is controlled
because you can't breathe in till you
get to the top so if you're doing a
drill where you're jumping and most of
the things we do our leg driven swimming
is mostly arms part of the reason why
people only use their arms is because
you use five times the oxygen with your
legs as you do with your arms so the
legs are very inefficient for swimming
but yet they create a lot of load on
your heart which that can boost your
breath holding and so there's a bunch of
other other things that happen but a lot
of it is just that environment is very
protective so for recovery too for like
what somebody's got a hurt knee hurt hip
hurt ankle you can go in there and start
moving dynamically early before you
would ever do it on land and be
protected so there's a bunch of you know
and then we could just Ratchet it up I
can make you know if I
I truly believe if you gave if you said
you know I'll get you Phelps is gonna
come to your house and you're gonna have
Phelps for three months I could make
Phelps faster yeah this is this is this
I'm so I'm he's doing a dunking drill
and he's using a medicine ball but he's
haven't he jump out of three feet of
water right
hmm so when he gets on land when he gets
on land it's like it's like a he it's
like a whole other game yeah it imagine
a whole nother game now did you invent
this protocol this whole thing of
yapping and doing in the water what what
motivated you well I came the original
concept came out of the drilled not a
drill a thing we used to do in the
summer when we were kids it's a Hawaiian
kind of Waterman drill where you run on
the bottom of stones scene BJ Penn does
that's yes you get a stone you run along
the bottom then you put it down then
your friend swims along the surface and
then when he when you go up he swims
down grabs it and then he goes along as
far as he can and you swim and you just
go back and forth until neither one of
you can do it
so his base kind of on that concept and
then but I wanted to expand that because
that's kind of limiting you just swim
and you run and you can't isolate
movements and you're not working
it like you can with dumbbells so now I
shift dumbbells into the water and and I
have all different weights so depending
on your skill level you know everything
we do and that's one thing about
everything that I'm involved in is is it
usually has to have a spec to be able to
be you know for everybody to do it it
has to be old people and kids too in my
mind that it's not viable
unless it's it you can appeal to
everybody that you need you need to a
kids need to be able to do it an old
person be able to really be valid that
really have legitimacy you know it's
like okay the coffee it has to be there
has to be things that the kids can can
have that creamer the old people can
have it it's gotta be can't just be
specialized I think the specialization
of some of this stuff is creates the
lack of validity I don't think that it's
valid if it's specialized and so I could
take a little kid like my daughter does
a bunch of the pool training stuff right
I have an older older guys that come and
do a bunch of the pool training stuff
you know I got Pat Riley comes in there
and he trains in the summertime with us
and stuff yeah yeah so we get a really
broad spectrum of people and that and
that confirms to me that it's really
legitimate right because then it's like
no this is real like the kids can do it
the whole people can do it the top guys
can do it the bottom guys can do it
everybody can do it that you know that
that's something that's that's I just
think that that's the you know what what
what is real so how many years even
doing this xpt well I mean the pool
training I've been I developed over the
last probably 10 to 12 years about 12
years now in the pool with any you've
evolved it so you start off with a
couple rdy before I had like a Velcro
weight jacket where you velcro like oh
yeah we yeah jump in the deep end it was
a little scary
I get the jacket off and now can you get
up so that wasn't that wasn't that
wasn't viable that was so then we moved
of dumbbells where you can drop them and
but we you know there's probably 20
exercises that we asked way to use and
it depends sometimes we're doing we have
a move called the gorilla where we're
using you know 60 to 70 70 pound
dumbbells where you're doing a curl
press jump so ugiy and you're jumping on
the slope so your curl
pressing and jumping with with with you
know 60 70 pound dumbbells depending on
your size we're swimming with 50 pounds
60 pound dumbbells we're jumping off the
bottom with 15 pound dumbbells it
depends on the exercise so it's all
depends on the person's skill what the
drill is but we I have a whole I have
all the weights next to the pool so we
have everything from 70s 2 to 5 pound
dumbbells I love that idea of the jump
press like doing some sort of a oh yeah
it's all you'd love it it's crazy I call
it the gorilla curl so it's a squat curl
press jump and then when you come out of
the water you just let the weights drop
and then the water catches it you could
never do that and how do you rip your
shoulder out right right how do you do
this in the water
well you vary on your height mm-hmm so I
have I have a about a 11 foot deep end
and then I have a slope so you can
choose every depth all the way and then
I have what you saw in that last video
it's about a three and a half foot
shallow end hmm so this is the first
pool I'm trying to build a couple I'm
trying to build one in Hawaii right now
that's that's gonna evolve from what I
learned from this pool so this pool I
just kind of built it with you know with
the hopes of designing a program and
then out of it came all day all this
stuff what are you gonna alter I'm gonna
create multiple depths so I'm gonna do
like an area that has 12 foot then we're
gonna shift back 2 feet and have a 10
foot and then another flat area of 8
foot and then another flat area a 6 foot
mm-hmm and then I have the magic width
is about somewhere between 35 to 40 feet
wide and that's like if you're trying to
swim a heavy dumbbell you know we do a
lot of individual limbs stuff so that
you isolate each limb so we'll do pistol
squats and Russians lunge squats and a
bunch of other you know and and
movements that you can you'd be very
vulnerable if you did that in the gym
you can chance or you could hurt
yourself but because you have that
stability in that environment it totally
supports you so you can you can be and
go into ranges of motions that you don't
have like you you know you might not be
able to go sink all the way down into a
deep lunge on one leg and press out with
dumbbells in your hand on
but in the water you can and the water
actually makes it lighter so you have to
boost the weight and stuff so there's a
bunch of great stuff that comes out of
it
that sounds very attractive to people
that have had injuries beautiful and
what but the irony is is it kind of it's
a little bit like what comes out of
rehab where you actually get better
performance - like you're like you know
a lot of a lot of rehab exercises become
performance driving exercises you know
it's like you don't do that [ __ ] only
when you get hurt start doing that and
get strong that way so then you maybe
you won't get hurt yes you know so it
comes that way - it goes both directions
hmm and do you have workouts that people
can follow online if someone goes to the
SPT life is xpt live yes
VT life website yeah well actually the
thing that we have the thing we have
right now that's probably the most the
most kind of prevalent one the thing
that's happening the soonest is we have
a breathing app coming out so we have a
breathing app that has almost every
different modality of breath work and so
there's some pretty cool stuff in there
where you can go choose hey before I go
to sleep or before my workout after my
workout you know during my thing so we
have a bunch of we have a pretty cool
breathing app that that we're working on
as well so